poursuit donc cette édition spéciale
consacrée à star 80 à la fiche depuis le
24 octobre est à présent ce sont peter
et sloane qui sont sur ce plateau
bonsoir à tous les deux vous m'en
voudrez pas je vais commencer plus tôt
avec ce clown plutôt qu'avec peter pour
savoir parce que vous êtes la seule
femme présente ce soir
comment ça se fait abbas est très
souvent c'est un petit peu la mascotte
de la troupe
parce que il ya moins de femmes que
d'hommes dans la troupe
et puis les autres femmes sont plus ou
moins c'est loin en france ou à
l'étranger donc voilà ça a été difficile
de s'imposer on vous parle non non non
parce que ils sont tous on se connaît
tous depuis des années ils sont à doha
puis j'ai pas toujours été tout seul il
ya eu desireless et sabrina vous vous
êtes épaules et voilà mais c'est vrai
que j'ai été beaucoup beaucoup tout seul
avec eux mais ma foi ça s'est très bien
passé
célébrons camarades donc il ya des
grosses périodes de crises de rire elle
fait sourire pour vous également comment
vous avez vécu ce tournage et cette
ambiance justement avec tous ces groupes
toutes ces vedettes des années 80 il a
été difficile pour chacun d'exister ou
pas
non pas du tout chacun son son titre son
tube ses tubes on se connaît depuis des
années
je chantais déjà dans les années 70 je
connaissais déjà les toulousains un
petit peu donc oui ça a été que des
retrouvailles on se retrouve très
souvent sur les plateaux 80 sur les
télés
les émissions de radio donc n'est pas
une découverte quoi la seule chose c'est
découverte du cinéma
ces moments très long mais qu'on a pris
avec beaucoup de joie de plaisir et un
film vraiment extraordinaire pour nous
pour notre premier film une journée de
tournage ça fait des fois une minute et
demie de film quand ils tour d'une
minute ils sont contents ils disent et
c'est frustrant pour vous pour ce rythme
justement qui est pas le même entre
celui de la musique de la chanson du
spectacle auront aussi fait parce que
tout est à voir et à comprendre à
découvrir dont c'était très très belle
aventure
j'espère
il ya une question quand on vous a
proposé ce scénario pour pour star 80 et
qui reprenait l'avis que vous aviez vécu
lors de la tournée justement vous avez
tout de suite dit oui
n'ayez pas peur aussi qui est un trait
qui soit qu'ils soient durcies que ça
tombe dans la caricature on voit à
l'écran vous avez des rapports très
explosif
tandil oui mais après on lit le scénario
on adapte on accepte tout on n'accepte
pas des shows loto de ce que vous avez
changé
oui certaines choses mais on a accepté
l'autodérision complètement parce que
nous on le fait depuis des années tous
les deux sur scène et l'autodérision
gros c'est drôle quoi donc
non les gens vont nous découvrir ou
redécouvrir parce que ceux qui nous ont
vus en concert franchement par moments
ils se disent enfin il chante mais il
joue la comédie sur scène aussi parce
qu'on n'arrête pas qu'on fait monter les
gens sketch sur scène depuis très
longtemps tous les deux donc en famille
qu'on adapte à chaque public c'est à
dire il ya beaucoup d'improvisation et
donc il ya quelque part un côté comédie
qu'on avait en nous et qu'on a recréé
thomas nous a laissé aller dans cette
voie là et des fois à pousser très fort
justement ce phénomène là et nous on
s'est énormément amusé c'est drôle je
suis bon c'est bon mais voilà c'est
juste pour ça qu'il est venu de faire
of code sac à merde
c'est quoi ce gloss la crème contre
l'herpès quoi